So how do we get access to this world partition?
Well, world partition comes with a template that we can access from our launcher.
So we can see here that the supported content, use one of these game templates,
can help ensure that your project is open world compliant right from the start.
So the blank, the first person, third person, top down and vehicle advanced are all project types
and templates that can operate within the world partition.
You can enable the needed features later on using games template,
just to ensure that you are set up for success from the start.
Next, we need to make sure streaming is enabled.
So if you do not use the template, you can go to the world settings and then under world partition.
So world settings can be found from a window at the top and go down to world settings.
World settings, you just want to go to this world partition section,
click enable streaming and this will set up the streaming portion.
But you still need to set up other items like world partition, one file per actor, data layers and HLOD.
So the template level that you'll open within your project, just from a new level box,
you can see that you can select the open world or empty open world
and it'll start you off in a new map that's ready to use most of the world tools.
So the default open world comes with, so if we select this new level,
that will come with world partition, one file per actor, data layers, the hierarchical level of detail,
which is a HLOD, it'll come with a sample 2K by 2K landscape, which you can see here,
with a landscape material and lighting set up for an outdoor environment,
which does a lot of the heavy lifting for you.
You also got use of the sky atmosphere here.
We've got the skylight, directional light, exponential height fog and also volumetric clouds.
So right out of the game, Unreal does a lot of the heavy lifting for us if we use this template open world.
Then looking at the grid of world partition.
So the second fact that we're using to determine whether a grid cell is loaded or unloaded at runtime
is the settings of the runtime grid itself.
So runtime grid settings are located in the world settings.
So again, go into that world settings panel.
And then in the world partition setup section, which you can see here,
we've got a 2D runtime hash grid that is provided by default.
So you can see this runtime hash.
So using more than one grid can negatively impact performance.
So you just want to really go with one grid setup as that will impact performance.
So size is in meters. So cell size, you've got meters there.
So 25,600 is 256 square meters for cell size.
So the 76,800 loading range is 768 meter radius around the streaming source.
So just to put those numbers into context, that's 768 meter radius around the streaming source.
And then you'll need to experiment as each project will have just different requirements
based on what you're trying to achieve here.
To give an overview of the streaming source.
So the streaming of grid cells within a grid at runtime is determined by two factors here.
We've got the streaming source and then we've also got the runtime grid settings.
The streaming source found on the left hand side here,
the components that define a position in the world and trigger the loading of cells around them.
So the player controllers in this instance are the streaming source.
Other streaming sources can be added to the world using world partition streaming source component.
If you want that extra functionality over who or what is a streaming source in the project.
When we're looking at streaming the grid, there are two components here.
That we're using for controlling the loading of cells around the streaming source.
So the streaming source components that define position in the world and trigger the loading of cells around them.
So again, like we said in the previous instance, you'll see the player controller here.
And the player controller is an example of the streaming source.
And then the grid determines whether a grid cell is loaded or unloaded at runtime based on the cell size and the loading radius.
So you can see these in the top down grid in action based on the settings that we set in the previous slide.
So in order to see the grid working, you'll need to make sure you have a streaming source,
which is usually the player seen in this image and then a content, some kind of content placed in the world,
which we're getting from this template.
So below the grid, you'll see a key that tells you what corresponds to the grid image.
So if you need to understand what you're visualizing here, you'll see that key.
And then you can also view the grid using the commands WP.runtime.toggle.drawruntime.hash2d.
And then also WP.runtime.toggle.drawruntime.hash3d.
So the hash2d and the hash3d. And if you type in these, it may just auto complete those as well.
You can find all this in the documentation as well.
So if we're looking at converting our existing worlds into world partition,
you can use the world partition conversion commandlet like we mentioned at the start.
So this is mainly for projects coming from UE4 that want to make the use of this UE5 feature.
So if your documentation is going to be your friend here,
you'll understand how to use this tool by digging into the documentation there.